[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 dans les
Yvelines et en Essonne l'association
Ensemble de générations proposent au
Seigneur d'accueillir et un étudiant ou
un jeune à leur domicile et aux jeunes
un logement chez l'habitant l'objectif
est simple offrir une réponse à la
difficulté d'accès au logement pour les
jeunes à la précarité étudiante et la
précarité des seniors et pour en parler
avec nous je suis aujourd'hui avec
Nicole Agius Morel et Charlotte Nando
bonjour bonjour Alors Charlotte vous
êtes donc étudiante et vous Nicole vous
êtes donc retraités vous avez accueilli
une étudiante à votre domicile comment
est-ce que vous avez connu justement
l'association Ensemble de générations en
fait j'ai que j'ai accueilli des
étudiants de depuis longtemps mais
c'était par l'intermédiaire d'amis et
une étudiante turque une étudiant
étudiant d'origine
hindoue et
on essaie de mon mari
j'avais envie de justement j'avais
j'avais apprécié ce présent et
le hasard a fait que une amie m'a parlé
des générations deux et c'est comme ça
qu'il y a deux ans j'ai un colis une
Roxane et cette année une Zara voilà
donc c'est de toute façon ça a été une
volonté déjà même avant d'accueillir une
composition et
vous Charlotte du coup comment est-ce
que vous avez connu moi c'est par le
biais de mes parents parce que c'était
le moment où je devais trouver un
logement quand j'ai choisi mes études
donc c'était soit habité en appartement
soit faire une colocation et le trouver
une association intergénérationnelle je
connaissais pas du tout donc c'est en
fait c'est grâce à mes parents que j'ai
pu connaître le concept et qu'est-ce qui
vous a plu justement dans les objectifs
et les ambitions de l'association ce
serait que même en tant que jeune on
peut se dire moi j'ai envie de profiter
un petit peu de ma vie on peut avoir
peur aussi d'être
enfermé finalement rejoignant ce
dispositif est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
vous a permis justement et quels sont
les les comment dire les aspects
positifs je dirais que j'aime beaucoup
le contact avec les les gens tout
simplement donc ça me dérange vraiment
pas de d'être avec une senior et de
discuter et surtout en tant qu'étudiante
je viens de assez loin donc je me suis
dit pour la première année c'est
intéressant de ne pas être seul de pas
être forcément isolé et de justement
partager mon année avec avec quelqu'un
et c'est vrai que l'entraide elle est
très enrichissante au quotidien j'en
apprends beaucoup donc voilà je regrette
pas et vous qu'est-ce qui vous a plu
aussi sur les objectifs
tout de suite vraiment emballé parce que
c'est un échange une écoute et une
prolongation le l'étudiant j'ai eu un an
depuis pendant 3 ans c'était pendant le
covid en plus et ben on se voit toujours
je suis la Mamita voilà de la famille et
là après ça a été Roxane ses parents
étaient à Triel et c'était aussi un
échange des personnalités différentes ça
fait des ouvertures ça fait vous aviez
évoqué tout à l'heure l'importance pour
les seniors de l'informatique
donc j'apprécie ça aussi beaucoup
et puis voilà c'est une entraide une
façon de se sentir utile de leur recréer
un foyer de des échanges mut de services
tout en gardant son territoire ces
libertés sans contrainte il faut qu'on
se sente à l'aise et
un partage voilà qui soit alors
justement vous vous montrez que
l'échange le partage et la bienveillance
peut-être possible entre entre deux
générations Sherlock la précarité
étudiante fait beaucoup débats notamment
à l'Assemblée nationale trouver un
logement se nourrir et poursuivre ses
études c'est parfois compliqué alors
est-ce que c'est cet aspect là aussi qui
vous a permis justement de rejoindre
l'association oui c'est sûr que ça pèse
beaucoup dans la balance de pouvoir
avoir un logement qui est pas forcément
très très cher surtout quand on trouve
une école et qu'il faut la financer et
qu'il faut effectivement se nourrir
voilà ça ça devient assez compliqué donc
le fait de non seulement cohabiter avec
quelqu'un et que ce soit aussi une
expérience c'est pour moi c'était très
intéressant donc bien sûr le côté
précarité joue beaucoup et même question
pour pour vous Nicole l'après le karité
ne touche pas seulement les étudiants ça
touche aussi les seniors mais depuis le
covid neuf la France est en pleine prise
de conscience face à la solitude dont
souffre de nombreuses personnes âgées
pourquoi avoir accès accepté
d'accueillir un étudiant à votre
domicile en lien avec le dispositif
ensemble de générations
des services qu'on se rend mutuellement
et qui fait que le lien se crée et que
on se rendait ça fait des présents c'est
des échanges de culture des échanges de
mode de vie de façon de voir les choses
qui sont très enrichissantes aussi bien
pour l'un que pour l'autre donc on peut
se rendre des services mutuels en
général ils ont ils se nourrissent un
peu d'une façon aléatoire donc là pour
eux faire manger plus de fruits plus de
produits des petits gâteaux on fait des
gâteries enfin bon moi ça me dérange pas
de faire la cuisine donc voilà on
partage des repas mais sans que ce soit
obligatoire quand tes horaires
coïncident ou pas c'est il y a pas de
règles fixes il faut qu'on se sente à la
fois libre et proche voilà aussi on
pourrait penser finalement que justement
les donc les jeunes sont là pour faire
attention au Seigneur et c'est peut-être
la mission justement principale mais de
ce que vous me dites on a l'impression
aussi que les seniors font aussi
attention aux jeunes c'est ça je trouve
oui mais c'est la sensation que vous
avez aussi Charlotte avec votre Seigneur
oui totalement ce que c'est vrai que
côté nourriture parfois
et même quand on a des petits coups de
blues qu'on a dans mon cas je suis très
loin de ma famille donc c'est sûr
qu'elle a elle apporte un peu ce côté
familial chaleureux que j'apprécie
beaucoup alors est-ce qu'il y a eu un
entretien justement préalable pour voir
si le lien se faisait naturellement au
sein de votre duo oui moi du coup
c'était en visio mais on a quand même pu
s'appeler et voir comment s'entendait en
quelque sorte donc évidemment le le
feeling passe bien donc mais elle a plus
vu ma mère d'abord mais moi j'ai et ça
se passait très bien alors Charlotte
quels sont vos missions justement au
quotidien avec avec votre Seigneur alors
moi c'est plutôt assis libre je sais
qu'il y a plusieurs formules mais c'est
vrai que j'apporte toujours une petite
aide au quotidien on s'est bien sûr pas
c'est naturel j'ai envie de dire parce
que on habitait ensemble pour moi c'est
un peu comme ma grand-mère en fait donc
ça me dérangeant pas de l'aider et puis
elle aussi elle m'aide comme on vient de
le dire donc que ça peut être aidé à
faire des courses ou aider à chercher le
courrier ou même plutôt moi je l'aide
pour l'orthographe parfois c'est le
c'est l'autre sens donc voilà c'est pas
grand chose vraiment et je tiens à me
reprendre parce que j'ai dit votre
senior ou votre étudiante mais c'est
juste une cohabitation donc vaut mieux
dire le jeune ou la jeune qui qui est
avec vous pardon dans le logement
au-delà de l'échange et du lien que vous
créez justement est-ce que vous Nicole
vous apprenez encore des choses à
travers justement les les études de
l'étudiante qui partage votre votre
logement oui bien sûr
l'an dernier c'est de la jeune fille que
j'avais Roxane fait des études de droit
donc voilà ça m'a donné des ouvertures
de ce côté-là après la présenter le
barreau tout ça elle avait donc c'était
aussi cette année c'était des études de
langues et alors ça rejoint un petit peu
votre problème parce que votre famille
est loin et là aussi ça sa famille est
loin donc voilà j'essaye de remplacer de
recréer justement
si on sait pas c'est pas facile pour un
jeune quand il est aussi quand il y a
des moments difficiles tout ça c'est
bien d'avoir quelqu'un une écoute le
lien se fait aussi un peu plus
facilement finalement quand la personne
quand la personne est loin comment
l'association Ensemble de génération
justement vous a accompagné dans ce
nouveau mode de vie comment est-ce
qu'ils vous ont préparé alors
madame peineau donc viens voir le ce
qu'on propose comme logement
ensuite moi en général je suis pas là
pendant les vacances donc c'était avant
les vacances et après on a un
rendez-vous avec l'étudiant pour qu'ils
contactent tout ça en général là c'était
c'était vraiment là et par exemple l'an
dernier et c'était un Fabricio qui était
du Pérou il était des études de
conservatoire de Versailles et
ce cas c'est qu'il avait oublié de dire
qu'il était un peu asthmatique
allergique aux chats et j'ai une chatte
c'est un peu compliqué
si ce n'est que ça ça va mais voilà il y
a le suivi de toute façon pour savoir si
tout va bien alors justement les jeunes
et les personnes âgées ont parfois du
mal à cohabiter les seigneurs estiment
que les jeunes n'ont pas leur mot à dire
sur certains sujets qu'ils n'ont rien
vécu et les jeunes estiment que les
personnes âgées sont des râleurs qu'ils
n'ont plus leur mot à dire leur que
répondre à ces personnes qui pensent
finalement qu'une cohabitation entre la
jeune et l'ancienne génération n'est pas
possible bon je trouve que c'est
complètement faux
bon j'ai la chance de toujours bien
m'entendre avec les jeunes et
vice-versa et au contraire non c'est on
apprend les uns des autres
pareil pour pour vous Charlotte oui
comme j'ai dit au début c'est ça apporte
beaucoup parce qu'on parle de tellement
de sujets l'amour les études le travail
tout donc c'est très enrichissant il y a
pas ce côté de toi tu es jeune tu sais
pas ou l'inverse
une personne et on parle et c'est
incroyable je trouve en vous voyant même
si vous ne vous connaissez pas
directement qu'il y a énormément de
bienveillance et c'est très positif et
c'est surtout à retenir justement dans
dans ce dispositif donc par ensemble de
générations merci beaucoup Nicole et
Charlotte d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation on peut avoir plus
d'informations sur le site ensemble de
génération.fr et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]